yeah new five minute game playing Marco
from from from from Greece of course and
is this let's just check it clog your
spa roses understood vice president of
video or something I'm not quite sure
what his official position is but it's
some feeder feeder guy okay it's um
accelerated dragon and which one's
supposed to yeah a regular dragon set up
with f3 the you Slav attack I think it
is called hmm I don't really know the
theory this is not a good sign probably
there's a multitude of exchange sacs and
stuff but wait wait wait I think Bishop
h6 r oopsie three-year this is the line
problem
Wow yeah this opening is really
something else
what now is he threatening something I'm
not sure even g5 is this possible let's
go
Queen c3 may be threatening Queen a1 and
taking on d4 so probably on twin c3 I
need to go and king bee one first
yeah and he I thought might f5 maybe
read c3 it's still king b1 the bishop on
sis don't be 3 is really next an
excellent play an excellent piece I
don't
I simply cannot spend like five minutes
no need to go here ah Queen C 3 I can
even take you seven wait d7 and c8 but
maybe it is something something like a
perpetual then I took it I mean just
took it okay
hmm twin takes yeah if I go king before
now this may be this a silly move like
not see form and I need to take it
rook takes and that I probably passed it
hmm that's no fun
okay I take age five maybe
yeah probably need to do this anyway how
am I going to make progress without the
smooth the question is if you give this
check now King the two king the Queen D
for do I actually go back or can I go to
e2 even trying to win this actually I
think I can he doesn't he doesn't even
have a checker after the smooth this is
funny
okay I can give I can give this check on
c3 of course and well here I don't have
any any any choice Jack Queen c3
yeah King E - there's Queen f3 this is
this is entirely ridiculous yes so on
she just going to to draw maybe Jack
yeah the quests the problem is if I go
here between f3 check and then Queen
takes a try Fanta Scott like all paths
304 for Alise reports I'm not sure if
black needs to make the draw yeah
exactly
g6 is the Moose that I was thinking
about of course if I go king b1 does
this not see for this is nonsense if I
go F 6 o f6 wait wait wait wait f6 f6
maybe layers also has got this check
okay come from g6 that's let's be quick
here oh he can always force the draw I
think I I didn't have any way to to to
avoid that at least I'm threatening me
to myself now so I cannot cannot place
on some some slow move
okay just just briefly consider bishop
of seven months was probably idiotic I
can take it I still think it's a draw
actually don't think he has got a way to
him - what if I go King me - is this
completely insane
it looks insane we have three Qingyi one
that's probably it's just a blitz game
yeah they cannot go Queen III he needs
to I can't give Queen you forecheck yeah
and this is actually a completely fine
24 I can play okay now how do you check
me now Queen Queen g6 Queen g6 26
okay so it wasn't such a great idea to
play for win here
check yeah I should have just taken the
draw time you need to Queenie to really
what sir
yeah what's a bit too much check check
check check check check check check
yeah but it's the community window of
course check check check
check
check check check check check
yeah well okay I should have just taken
the draw I didn't see that you can can
take on g6 simply yeah I just I just
need to need to draw this with King c1
over look here this this sequence was
Queen g6 of course yeah also was a bit
down on time so I need to go king c1
playing playing playing the draw so
probably the the logical result of the
game yeah thanks for watching